Hello everyone,
welcome to our lecture.
This is a new
lecture that
Dr. Poo and I
put together.
We're trying to
integrate the
structure and
function to help you
identify the
lesions in the CNS.
So first of all,
here's our contact
information and
there's a fun
photo for me
playing table tennis
at the National
Senior Olympics.
And here's Dr.
Poo's fun photo
too. She'll tell
you more about it.
Hi, this is Dr.
Poole here. And yeah,
that's just me with a
skull of a Parasaurolopis.
It's one of the
dinosaurs, sort of
related to the things
I studied. And it's
just, that's just
the skull there. It's
got this wild crest
going back from the
head that contains
the nasal passages. So
weird skulls. All
right. So this lecture,
we're going to do mostly
review materials. So
you're going to see a
lot of the slides that
are sort of empty, and
we're expecting you
to pause the slide,
pause the video to fill
in the blank yourself
first. And then you
can look at the answers
in the next slide.
So today, we're going
to be first reviewing
the blood supply of
the central nervous
system, and I'll be
walking you through that.
Then Dr. Shi will
take over, and she's
going to help you
differentiate the major
functions of different
lobes, as well as
reviewing the major sensory
and motor functional
systems. By that,
we mean those tracts
heading up and down
through the brain.
And she'll also
go through those
cerebellar
pathways with you.
Then finally, I'll be
back at the end to go
through some example
questions that will help
to integrate the structure
and the function,
and basically looking
at clinical symptoms
and using those to
help identify where a
particular lesion in
the brain is occurring.
And especially we're
going to link that
back to that blood
supply and talk
about this in the
context of strokes.
So before we start, a
lot of this is review
and we're going to
ask you to test where
your knowledge
currently is by sort of
drawing out or
labeling certain things
we're showing you.
So make sure you have
some way of doing that
prepared and go ahead
and pause this and
give yourself enough
time to draw out
those structures or
whatever it is that
we're asking you to do.
So first off, let's
review those blood
supplies of the
central nervous system.
So,
what two major
arteries and their
branches supply the
brain and at least
the upper portion
of the spinal cord?
So that is the
vertebral artery for
the posterior
circulation and the
internal carotid
artery for the
anterior circulation
in the brain.
so now uh sketch out
that circle of willis
all right i'll draw
out that blood supply
to the brain and
then we'll come back
and we'll check on
what that looks like so
here we have the
circle of willis and
technically the circle
itself is just this portion
that we see here but
imagine we're looking
up at the ventral
surface of the brain.
This is a cut
surface here where
the internal
carotid artery is
coming up away from
the inner surface
of the skull and
into the brain,
and it has
several branches.
First, I'll mention
the middle cerebral
artery. That's not
technically part of
the circle of Willis
because it doesn't
participate in this
loop here, but it
does come from the
internal carotid artery,
and it's an important
blood supply
to the lateral portions
of the cerebrum.
Next up, we have the
anterior cerebral
artery, which is
coming anteriorly from
the internal carotid.
And then the left
and the right are
joined here by this
very short anterior
communicating artery.
And so these anterior
cerebral arteries are
technically part of
that circle of Willis,
as are this posterior
portion here, which is
the posterior
communicating artery, which
connects from the
internal carotid artery
back to the posterior
cerebral artery. Now the
posterior cerebral
artery is really a branch
of this basilar artery,
and that's why this
is called the
posterior communicating
artery. It is the connection
between this anterior
blood supply coming
from the internal
carotid and this posterior
blood supply coming
from, ultimately, the
vertebral arteries.
So if we go all the
way back to those,
starting from
the vertebral
arteries on either side,
they come together
and join together to
form the basilar
artery. And this sits on
the anterior or ventral
side of the pons.
But before we
get to that,
coming off the vertebral
arteries before
they join into the
basilar artery is pica,
the posterior inferior
cerebellar artery.
And that obviously
contributes blood
supply to the
cerebellum, but also to
the lateral portion
of the medulla.
Similarly, we have this
anterior spinal artery,
which, as the
name implies, will
continue along the
spinal cord and supply
it, but it also along
the way supplies
the medial portion
of the medulla.
After those vertebral
arteries joined
into the basilar artery,
they then give off
anterior inferior
cerebellar arteries,
which again
supply portions of
the cerebellum,
but also the
lateral portion
of the pons.
Then along the
basilar artery, there
are these small
pontine arteries
that supply portions
of the pons.
Then up here you
have these two major
arteries that split
off from the end of the
basilar artery and
those are the superior
cerebellar artery and
then the posterior
cerebral artery
which we've already
mentioned so the superior
cerebellar artery
obviously again supplying
the superior portion
of the cerebellum
and some of the
midbrain along the way
the posterior cerebral
artery will supply
portions of the temporal
and occipital lobes
of the cerebrum.
So let's take
a step back and
look at the
bigger picture.
Think back to anatomy.
Can you think about
where, what is the
pathway to get from the
aorta to the internal
carotid artery or to
the vertebral artery?
And here's what we're
looking at. So on the
left side here, we have
this sort of schematic
look at all of these
arteries in the head
and neck. And I know
there's a lot of things
going on there, but
we're just going to
use it to look at these
particular pathways.
So on the left
side here, I have
marked out the
pathway to that
anterior supply
to the brain.
That's the internal
carotid pathway.
So here we're on the
right side of the
body. So we're going
to pass through the
great brachiocephalic
artery and then to
the common carotid
artery that continues
up. It branches here
into the external
carotid artery, which
we're not concerned with
here, and the internal
carotid artery.
All right, that works
its way up through
the skull and
then here to the
circle of Willis. So
here's where it gives
off that middle
cerebral artery and
then also the
anterior cerebral and
the posterior
communicating arteries.
And there's our circle.
On the right side
of this diagram,
I've indicated that
posterior supply.
So that's the pathway
to the vertebral artery.
So in this case,
we're on the left side
of the body. So we're
going to go right
from the aortic
arch to the left
subclavian artery. If
it were on the right
side, we'd first go
to brachiocephalic.
Then the vertebral
artery branches off from
the subclavian. It
goes up through the
transverse foramina of
the cervical vertebrae,
wraps around the
atlas here, and then
comes in through the
foramen magnum along
with the brainstem,
and then forms the
basilar artery, and
comes up here giving
off that last branch of
the posterior cerebral.
We can also see
here our posterior
inferior cerebellar,
anterior inferior
cerebellar, and superior
cerebellar arteries.
In this lateral view
on the right side of
your screen, here we
can see those pathways
again. So here is our
coming off the aortic
arch, the common carotid
on the left side,
leading to the internal
carotid artery,
and here you can
see it passing
through the carotid canal
and into the
cerebral portion.
Back here, we can see
off the subclavian
artery, that
vertebral artery, and
you can see here
passing through
those foramina in the
cervical vertebrae
and then coming
up here along the
brain stem forming
that basilar artery.
Now let's think about
the relationship
between that circle
of Willis and the
how the brain actually
fits into that.
All right so basically
where are you
going to draw in the
subdivisions of the
brain over that circle
of Willis diagram
you already have.
So we've got our
circle of Willis
diagram and you're going
to draw in some
lines marking the
midline and then
boundaries between the
forebrain, midbrain,
pawns, and medulla.
So go ahead and
add in where those
lines should be
on your diagrams.
All right and hopefully
you have lines that
look something like
this where we have the
forebrain really around
that whole circle
of willis the midbrain
remember gets blood
supply from the superior
cerebellar artery
as well as from the
posterior cerebral so
basically those two
big arteries should be
right around the
midbrain and then because
the forebrain is also
getting blood supply
from the posterior
cerebral artery I like to
to put that line
between forebrain and
midbrain right through
that posterior cerebral
artery, because it's
contributing to both.
The pons is basically
that whole area
right along the
basilar artery. And
then the medulla is
lower than that, so
where you have the
vertebral arteries.
So next, let's add
in some cranial
nerves. So now we're
going to ask you
to basically just
draw in a number to
represent the cranial
nerves in each
of the places where
those emerge from
the brain relative
to the arteries.
So think about
those relative
positions of the nerves
in terms of
where they are in
different parts
of the brain
stem or above
the brain stem.
In essence we want
you to to take a
bunch of numbers 1
through 12 which we have
just listed off to
the side here and
arrange them where
they should fit on
this diagram so go
ahead and take a
minute and think
about where all those
should be and add
those into your diagram
and hopefully
you've ended
up with something
like this
where we have our
olfactory nerve
on the ventral
side of that
cerebrum way up
in the forebrain
Your optic nerves
are actually right
in the middle of that
circle of Willis.
In the midbrain,
you should
have cranial
nerves 3 and 4.
And 3 actually comes
out right in between
that posterior cerebral
artery and the superior
cerebellar. uh four
the trochlear is an
odd one because it
actually emerges from
the dorsal side of
the brain stem of the
midbrain specifically
and kind of wraps around
the lateral side to get
around to the ventral
side so we've placed
it more laterally uh
within the pons you
have cranial nerves
five six seven and
eight uh five is the
trigeminal nerve that
comes out more laterally
and then right near
the base of the palms,
near the boundary with
the medulla, you have
six, the abducens,
most medially, then
seven, and then
eight, most laterally.
And then finally
in the medulla,
you have nine, ten,
eleven, twelve.
Nine and ten are very
close together here.
They're both
going to exit
the jugular
foreman together.
the accessory nerve
has its base really
beginning from the
spinal cord but it's
going to come up along
the lateral side of
the medulla and then
exit that jugular
foreman along with 9
and 10 and then the
hypoglossal nerve 12 is
closer to the midline
so remember this rule
of fours by Gates
and if you follow the
link, he actually gets
into a few more
specifics, but the really
important thing here
is, right, you've
got four cranial
nerves that emerge from
the medulla, four from
the pons, and then
four that are more
rostral to that, so
coming from the forebrain
and the midbrain.
And the other important
thing here is that
your motor nerves are
going to start closest
to the midline, and
these sensory nerves are
going to be more lateral
all right and note
that four here is a
motor nerve but like i
said it's it's a bit
of an exception because
it actually it does
begin medially but it
wraps around uh the
lateral side to get around
to the ventral portion
of the brain stem
so wherever you
had that drawn that
probably works for a
part of the pathway
uh and so that should
do it in terms of
our location of where
all of these cranial
nerves emerge relative
to the arteries and
here it is all together
in a ventral view
of the brain where
we can see that blood
supply along with the
cranial nerves and this
diagram labels the
arteries but it does
not label the nerve
so I'm just going to
run through them quickly
here so here is the
olfactory tract so
cranial nerve number
one technically is
actually little little
nerves coming off from
here passing through
into the nasal cavity
but here's our olfactory
tract here is the
optic nerve and the
optic chiasm that's
cranial nerve two here
is oculomotor cranial
nerve 3, and you can
see, as I mentioned
before, that's passing
right in between the
posterior cerebral
artery and the superior
cerebellar artery.
Then we have the
trochlear nerve,
cranial nerve 4,
is up over here,
wrapping around
the midbrain
to get to where
it needs to be.
next up we have the
abducens cranial nerve
six right here and
then moving our way
laterally we have seven
and eight all right
so here's the
facial nerve and the
vestibulocochlear nerve
and there's actually
sort of two different
roots here drawn from
the facial nerve but
that's both facial
then passing to the other
side of the anterior
inferior cerebellar
artery here we now
get into the medulla
and our cranial nerves
from there so most
medially we actually have
the hypoglossal that's
what we're seeing
right here with these
little rootlets and
that emerges in between
the pyramids and the
olive which is a little
hard to see on this
diagram but that's where
it is and then more
laterally we have
cranial nerves 9 and 10
and then here's 11
the accessory and you
can see it has this
long root coming up from
the spinal cord and then
another contribution
from the medulla and
then it's going to
exit the jugular
foreman along with 9 and
10 and then we have
our first our first two
spinal nerves here so
this is c1 this is c2
all right now that you've
looked at the blood
supplies let's look
at different functions
at different lobes
now hopefully you're
able to recognize
these structures that i
listed here with numbers
one through eight
and be sure to recognize
and remember the
functions of each structures
i'll give you some
time to pause here
and fill in the blank
now here's the
answer when you
look at these
one through eight
were you able to
get all of them
be sure to differentiate
all the primary
cortex for each function
here i just want
to mention one thing
that may not be
like readily recognizable,
you know, from
what we have so far.
For example, this
number two is the
frontal operculum, which
is part of the primary
gustatory cortex.
And, you know, this
gustatory cortex
actually has two parts.
Besides the frontal
cortex it also has
another major spot at
this insular cortex which
is hiding underneath
the lateral sulcus
here everything
else should be relatively
straightforward
and this is a
parasagittal view
of the brain again i have
numbers one
through seven here
and see if you could
recognize which
structure you
know the structure
name as well as their
function so please
pause here to fill
in your answer
and here is my
answer these are
all pretty
straightforward you
should know the
functions by now
okay now let's review
some of the major
sensory and motor
functional systems
we'll look at some
long tracks first
so the first track
here um i have listed a
bunch of questions
hopefully you could answer
these so please pause
here and then try to
answer these questions
first of all which
track is this one is this
ascending or descending
tract and then what
kind of modality
meaning is this sensory
or motor if it's sensory
what type of sensory
information does it
carry and how many
neurons really to form
this tract at what level
this tract degasit in
across the midline to
the other side and if
you have the lesion at
a specific level for
example medulla what
kind of deficits you
know which side the
deficits you're going to
see. So try to answer
these questions. Now
hopefully you are
able to answer all
these questions since
this is the review.
Briefly let's go over
these. So you should
be able to identify
this is our ascending
DC-ML pathway. So
DC is dorsal column
showing here and
then ml is our medial
lemniscus showing here
right so the this ml is
for the sensory pathway
it's mediating the
touch and proprioception
and usually for the
ascending pathways
there are three neurons
relay so you have your
first order neuron
or primary afferents
with their cell bodies
located in the dorsal
root ganglia. In the
DRG, these neurons
send out the axons. The
central terminal comes
to the spinal cord
dorsal column and
ascending ipsilaterally to
reach the dorsal
medulla where there is a
center-order neuron
located in these nucleus
gracilis and the nucleus
cunatus to send out
the axons and then
cross the midline to
form medial lemniscus.
Remember the secondary
order neurons is
always the ones that
decasites. So after it
crosses the midline and
forms the medial
lemniscus, it will go up to
reach the thalamus
where the third neuron
third order neurons
located and specifically
these would be in the
vpl since it's for
the body sensation right
coming from the spinal
cord so the vpl will
send out neurons will
send out axons to go
through the internal
capsule specifically
posterior limb of the
internal capsule So
to reach the primary
somatocentric cortex at
the postcentral gyrus.
So the level
of decusition
is at caudal medulla.
And if you have
any lesions
above this level,
then you would
see the contralateral
deficits.
And if you have the
lesions below this
level, for example,
in the entire spinal
cord, you will see
ipsilateral deficits.
so here are the
answers and if you need
more information
you can look at this
book you know the
notice the human brains
in photographs and
diagrams chapter
eight is for all the
functional systems
okay second tract
same thing pause here
and then answer these
questions please
so this is our
ascending spinal salamic
tract i just want to
emphasize one thing
that's uh it how it's
different from our
dcml pathway so it's
also the sensory it
carries the pain and
temperature information
also have three
neuron relays uh you
know with the primary
neurons at dorsal
root ganglion but then
the secondary order
neuron is really what
makes a difference
so the primary order
neuron sent in the
information to the
dorsal horn this is
where the secondary
neuron located and then
it crossed the
midline usually takes
about one to two segments
to completely cross
to the other side
and so still you know
the secondary order
neuron and the first
primary order neurons
are almost located
at the same level
so you know any of
the lesion to the
spinothalamic tract
almost always cause a
contralateral deficit
now let's look at
the third tract pause
here and answer these
questions please
you probably already
recognize this is our
major descending
pathway corticospinal
tract so the name of
cortical meaning it starts
from the cortex and
then comes all the
way down to the spinal
cord this is for
voluntary movement of the
body the corticospinal
tract is also called
a pyramidal tract
because it has the
major decomposition at
the pyramid so the
pyramidal tract comes
from this name for
this major descending
pathway it has two neuron
relays so the upper
motor neuron starts
from the very top
precentral gyrus where
the cell body located
and then this neuron
sends out the axons
down to the internal
capsule and then to
the midbrain cerebral
peduncle then the pons
at the ventral aspects
of the pons and
then medulla at the
pyramid so here it cross
the midline goes to
the other side forming
this lateral
corticospinal tract and
then synapse at this
lower motor neuron at
the ventral horn of
the spinal cord so this
is lower motor neuron
but directly innervating
the muscles to
produce the movement
so here are the answers
to all the questions
now let's take a
moment to really
reflect on you
know what are the
upper motor neuron
and lower motor neuron
lesions will present
as the deficit so make
sure you compare the
corticospinal tract and
the corticobulbar
tract which you know is
the brain stem right
the corkobovar tract
innovating the brain
stem nuclei and you can
see there are some
general rules but there's
also exceptions so
make sure you think
about what are the
exceptions for these now
let's look at
the answers so
first of all the
upper motor neuron
is producing
everything up.
You can see even with
the Babinski sign,
the toes will
fang up, right?
So you can remember
this upper motor
neuron, everything
goes up, and then lower
motor neuron,
everything goes down.
And for the lateralization,
you should be
able to figure out for
lower motor neuron,
it's always ipsilateral
deficits. But for
upper motor neuron,
depending on the level
of lesion it can
be either ipsy or
contralateral deficit
for the cortical bulbar
tract this is a different
story if you recall
the cortical bulbar
tract the upper motor
neuron is almost
always bilaterally
innervating the lower
motor neuron so you would
still have the lower
motor neuron lesion
that you know you
have the ipsilateral
deficits however for
the upper motor neuron
lesion, you almost never
see the deficits here.
There are exceptions
to these rules. So
first of all, for the
upper motor neuron of
the corticobulbar
tract, so we're talking
about the brainstem
nuclei innervation, there
is one exception for
the facial nucleus.
If you recall from Dr.
Curse's lecture the
lower half of the
face is innervated not
bilaterally by the
upper motor neuron but
only if uh contralaterally
by the upper
motor neuron so if you
have upper motor neural
lesions for the you
know innervating the
facial nuclei then
you would see the
contralateral deficits
for only lower half of
the face and then
for the lower motor
neurons the eye muscles
you know, because Dr.
Curse did not exclude
all the eye movement
muscles. So, you
know, for all of these
cranial nerve 3, 4,
and 6, they are the
exceptions for this
type of ipsilateral
deficits. So let's take
a close look at those.
now pause here to
see if you could fill
in these question
marks so I have used a
color coding and you
can also use your color
paint to fill in the
functions and the
structures now let's
look at the answers
so the pink nucleus
is oculomotor nucleus
and it has two
subdivisions for the nerve
fibers coming out
of the oculomotor
nucleus so you have
these inferior division
that are innervating
the inferior ******
inferior oblique and
medial ****** and then
you also have We
have another superior
division that's being
innovated, being sent
to the contralateral
side to innovate
the superior obliques,
the superior ******,
as well as the levator
palpabri superioris
for the eyelid.
This is not for the
eyeball itself, but for
the eyelid movement.
and then cranial nerve
4 is the cochlear
nucleus and chocolate
nerve as you can
see here the chocolate
nerve is actually
going out of the
brain and then make a
detour to exiting
the dorsal aspects of
the brain. So it's the
contralateral nucleus
that's sending out
the nerve to the
contralateral side,
as you can see here.
And then the green is
the abducens nucleus
and then it's simple
enough to innervating
ipsilateral lateral
******. However,
the interneurons in
the abducens nucleus
also activates the
contralateral oculomotor
nerve through MLF. So
the medial longitudinal
fasciculus mediating
these conjugated
movements of the two
eyeballs. So when
you have, you know,
let's say if you look
to the right, your
lateral nucleus will
innervate the right
side of the lateral
****** to look right and
then also innervating
the left medial ******
to make the left
eyeballs look right
as well. So you have
conjugated movements
of the two eyeballs.
Another thing I'd
like to mention is the
parasympathetic
function for running
along this inferior
division of the crinoneb
-3. So this is through
the EW nucleus
to mediate bilateral
pupil sphincter and
ciliary muscles to
produce the accommodation
as well as the
pupil light reflex.
So as you can
see here, there
are all sorts
of exceptions.
So you have, you
know, the ipsilateral,
contralateral, and
bilateral innervations
for all three different
nerves and nuclei.
Speaking of the
light reflex, do you
do remember the
the pathway please
pause here and
fill in the blanks
so the sensory
information from the
flashlight will uh go
through the retina to
reach the cranial nerve
number two right so
the optic nerve sent
in the information to
reach the midbrain
pre-tectile nucleus.
These pre-tectile
nucleus will send out
bilateral innervation
to activate the
EW nucleus, which
will mediate this
parasympathetic
innervation through the
cranial nerve number
three to reach the
sphincter pupillae to
have these bilateral
iris in a pupil
constriction.
all right let's
review the
major cerebellar pathways
first of all fill
in the anatomy
so pause here
and then try
to fill in all
these structures
by the letters
here are the
answers i just
want to emphasize
the three
cerebellar peduncles
this is the
anterior view of the
cerebellum when
it's peeled off from
the brain stem you
can clearly see the
three cerebellar
peduncle so this
is our superior
cerebellar peduncle
and this is our middle
massive bunch of
fibers and then
this is our inferior
cerebellar peduncle
now take a close
look at these three
images are you able
to identify which
peduncle these are and
then especially figure
out what kind of
information they're
receiving from and what
is their final destination
so pause here and
then try to fill in
the answers so how
do you identify these
three peduncles you
just need to remember
that you know the superior
cerebellar peduncle
attached to the
midbrain identified
here by the substantia
***** and our middle
cerebellar peduncle
attached to the palms
so you know you can
see this big puffy
structure and our inferior
cerebellar peduncle
attached to the medulla
you can see here
the inferior olivary
nucleus right very big
and so you know it's
really making sense
to have these superior
midbrain, middle
with palms, and then
inferior with medulla.
Their functions are
also very distinct.
So the superior
cerebellar peduncle
is the major cerebellar
efferent pathway.
So these efferent
fibers coming from
the cerebellar cortex
Purkinje cells,
they innervate the
dentate and interpose
the nuclei to form
this ipsilateral
superior cerebral
peduncle. And then when
they reach the midbrain,
they will decusset
and through this
decussition to reach
the contralateral
side of the thalamus.
Specifically, it's
the ventral lateral
nucleus of the
thalamus to help
coordinate their motor
the motor functions.
For the middle
cerebellar peduncles is
one of the major
afferent pathways that's
coming from the
cortex. So the cortical
pontine tract send the
axons to synapse at
the pontine nuclei
and then these pontine
nuclei send a bunch
of fibers goes to
the contralateral
side through these
middle cerebellar
peduncle, they actually
form the mossy fiber
to reach the cerebellar
cortex, most majority
at the lateral
and medial part of
the cerebellar cortex.
An inferior cerebellar
peduncle has two
major parts of
afferent fibers sending
into the cerebellum.
One is the vestibular
nucleus and also
the spinal cord.
These are going
through the ipsilateral
inferior cerebellar
peduncle,
also part of the
mossy fibers to reach
the vermis,
floccular nodular and
medial part of the
cerebellar cortex.
And another aspect
is from inferior
olivary nucleus.
remember this
big nucleus from
the medulla,
they actually
cross the midline
decacit to reach
the counter,
to go through the
contralateral side
of the inferior
cerebellum peduncle
to form these
climbing fibers.
And for the most part
reaching, you know,
all different parts
of the cerebellum,
including the lateral
part, to also help
with facilitating
the motor planning.
So in the end, you
can see that ascending
fibers, I mean, afferent
fibers has one cross
of the midline, right?
So they cross to the
other side. And then
the afferent fibers also
cross again to the other
side. So the double
crossing makes the
cerebellum innervating
the ipsilateral functions
and coordinating
the ipsilateral side
of the motor movement.
And that's why
when you have
cerebellar lesions,
the deficit
would be on the
ipsilateral side.
So here is a summary
slide. So hopefully
you can really fill in
the blank yourselves.
The answer is in
the next slide.
I'm not going
to go through
these answers one by one.
You can take a
look, and then if
you have questions,
let me know.
Hi, everyone. It's
Dr. Poole, and I
am back to finish
out this lecture
with a couple of
example questions.
We're going to use
these questions to
help integrate the
structure and the functions
in order to
identify and connect
clinical symptoms and
signs with lesions,
lesions in particular
areas of the brain.
Now when we say
lesion, that could be a
******, it could be
a tumor, it could be
anything that's
causing changes within
the structure from
its normal function.
In order to fully
integrate this along with
the blood supply, we're
mostly going to be
using ****** and
aneurysm as our examples.
Now one note about the
content here, these
are what I would
say board-style
questions. So some of
them may be a bit more
difficult than what
you would expect on
your upcoming exam,
but there are still
nice examples to talk
through and think
about the logic of
all of this. And
they're certainly
representative of what you
will expect on board
exams ultimately.
So we have a couple
of examples here and
then we're also going
to be doing a live
review session with
more of these. So
we do encourage you
to come to that as
well. But these couple
of examples will
give you a sense of
what that session is
going to be like. So
let's get into it.
So here's case
one. We have a 35
-year-old female
presenting to the
emergency department
with complaints
of diplopia and
severe headache.
History reveals
these symptoms have
progressed over several
days, and physical
examination reveals
lateral strabismus,
ptosis, and pupillary
dilation for
the left eye.
So if we break this
down, and this is
a really classic
presentation of what
we're talking
about here, lateral
strabismus just means
her eye is deviated
laterally. She
cannot put that left
eye so it's facing
exactly forward.
Ptosis just
means that left
eyelid is drooping a bit,
the left upper
eyelid specifically,
all right, and her
pupil is dilated.
Now motor examination
reveals normal
strength and range of
motion for her upper
and lower extremities,
and a CT scan of
the head and orbits
reveals an aneurysm.
So which of the following
is the most
likely location?
So the first things
that we want to
think about here are
which structure is
damaged and on
which side. And from
there, we can then
proceed to figuring
out which artery
would be impacted.
So once again,
here is the image
from Dr. Kurtzer's
lecture, along
with the text of
that question.
And so really what
we're looking for
is where are we
going to have the
combination of
symptoms or things that
are controlling,
right? That lateral
motion of the eye,
so what's going to
end up giving you
lateral strabismus,
ptosis, and dilation
of the pupil.
So if we're looking
at her left eye,
that's going to be
this eye over here,
okay? And so we know
that levator palpebrae
superioris is not
working. That's what's
giving her ptosis, and
that's along the purple
line. So over on this
side, the same as
superior ******, we
follow that purple line
back, all right, and
that gives us some
indication of where
that course needs to be.
Now we also know she
has lateral strabismus,
so that means probably
her abducens nerve
is working fine, and
that lateral ****** is
abducting or laterally
deviating her eye, but
she doesn't have
muscles to counter that.
And the muscle that
would normally counter
that is the medial
******. So that's a good
indicator that it's
her oculomotor nerve
involved, and specifically
this portion here
leading to medial ******.
So that's the lower
portion of oculomotor
nerve, whereas levator
palpibrae superioris,
this purple line,
was coming from the
superior portion.
But if we follow
them back here,
here they diverge
again. So somewhere
along this pathway,
right here, that is where
this injury most
likely is occurring.
Because if it were at
the nucleus itself,
then you would expect
the lateral strabismus
and the ptosis to be
happening on opposite
sides because of the
way those muscles
are innervated from
the nuclei. All right,
those upper muscles
being contralateral
to their nucleus makes
a difference there.
And then the third
symptom we're dealing
with is not shown on
this diagram, but that
pupillary dilation,
that's controlled from
the Edinger-Westfall
nucleus, which is
nearby here, and
that's controlling the
parasympathetics to the
eye. But again, fibers
from that nucleus will
join with the oculomotor
nerve and would be
found along here
and without the
parasympathetic innervation
then there's only
sympathetics that are
unopposed and the
sympathetics dilate the
pupil that's why you get
the pupillary dilation
okay and like i said
this is a really
classic presentation
of oculomotor nerve
palsy and we're looking
at the nerve itself
and not any of the
individual nuclei eye.
So that's our
damaged structure.
It's our left
oculomotor nerve. So
now we can think about
which artery is affected.
Since we know it's
the left oculomotor
nerve, it seems unlikely
that it's a right
-sided artery. So
we can go ahead and
rule out D and E,
even though posterior
communicating artery
and posterior cerebral
artery are both
pretty decent options.
Going back to the
top of the list here,
the anterior
communicating artery is
really too far
anterior, it's not going
to be involved here,
and the same goes
for that left anterior
cerebral artery.
And that leaves
us with our left
posterior
communicating artery.
We look at, again,
this ventral view
of the brain. Here's
that oculomotor
nerve emerging from
the midbrain, and
you can see that
it comes out in
between the the
posterior cerebral artery
and the superior
cerebellar artery.
So theoretically,
aneurysms on either
of these in the right
spot can impact the
oculomotor nerve.
But notice how after
it comes out, the
oculomotor nerve,
it's running parallel
to the posterior
communicating artery
for a decently
long distance, and
really the whole
distance of the
posterior
communicating artery.
So when oculomotor
nerve palsy is caused
by an aneurysm, it
is most commonly
that posterior
communicating artery.
And in this case,
it's going to be the
left posterior
communicating artery.
And that left
oculomotor nerve
is the structure
that's impacted
by pressure from
that aneurysm.
Now, looking at case
two, here we have a
25-year-old man coming
into the emergency
department feeling
dizzy, nauseated, and
unstable while walking
since he underwent a
chiropractic treatment
for neck pain several
hours ago. So physical
exam reveals absent
pinprick and temperature
sensation on his
right face and his
left trunk and limbs,
ataxia in the
right extremities,
left beating nystagmus,
and hoarseness. So
which of the following
additional findings
is most likely in
this patient so again
what we need to think
about here are what
structures were damaged
in the first place
and at what level
and on which side and
sort of think about what
other structures are
nearby there that
haven't been accounted
for and then we can
figure out which of
these options is is
going to be the best so
let's take a look at
a few things here so
again here's that view
of the ventral view
of the brain and we're
going to review here
this tract in
particular and hopefully
you recognize especially
looking at the
spinal cord cross section
with this immediate
crossover, that this
is the spinothalamic
tract. So remember
that our spinothalamic
tract is crossing over
more or less at the
level where those
neurons are coming into
the spinal cord, all
right? And then here
in the medulla, in
blue here, we have the
equivalent of the
spinothalamic tract in
the face, and that's
coming through that spinal
portion of the
trigeminal nucleus and
that is then pretty much
immediately crossing
over in the medulla
to come to this side.
So whenever we see this
situation where you
have absent pinprick
and temperature on
one side of the face
but the opposite side
of the limbs there's
really only one level
where that can be
happening and that's
here in the medulla all
right because at this
point a lesion on this
side in the diagram
would produce problems
with the ipsilateral
side of the face but
the contralateral
side of the body
right because if we
mirror this tract over
to this side right it
would then eventually
cross over lower down
in the spinal cord all
right so the medulla
is the level where
those two tracts are
essentially on opposite
sides from each
other right once these
fibers from the bulbar
tract from the coming
from that spinal
trigeminal tract
cross over. Over here,
they're on the same
side. So through most of
the brain, they match
up. So already, we
need to be thinking
about the medulla just
based on this, the
absent pinprick and
temperature sensation
on one side of the
face, and then the
opposite side of the trunk
and limbs all right
automatically that
tells you we're in the
medulla so if we look
at a cross section
then of the medulla uh
and we're kind of we're
giving things away
a little bit here
here's our cross section
of the medulla and
we're looking at this
particular area
that's all supplied by
one artery and that's
pica all right that's
our posterior inferior
cerebellar artery
and so we are
looking at a case
here of lateral medullary
syndrome or
wallenberg syndrome
so now we need to
think about the other
things that are
happening here all
right so we've we've
covered that absent
pinprick and temperature
sensation. So
that's covering the
spinothalamic tract
and that trigeminal
tract here,
the descending
tract of 5.
Then the other
things, all right, we
have the ataxia in
the right extremities.
OK, well, that
can be explained
because we have
our inferior
cerebellar peduncle here.
So that's going to
be carrying inputs
from the right side
into the cerebellum.
And so that's going
to create that
ataxia, all right?
And with Wallenberg
syndrome in particular,
the patients will
have a tendency
to sort of fall
towards the side of
the lesion because of
that ataxia on that
side of the body.
We have left beating
nystagmus, All
right, so that's that
sort of involuntary
eye movement when
the patient is trying
to look in a
particular direction.
And even though the
vestibular nucleus is
associated with the
inner ear, it does have
to do with balance,
and that is connected
to that. So you tend
to get nystagmus when
there's damage to the
vestibular nucleus.
so we've pretty much
covered all of these
things around the
outside we have a couple
more things here we have
the nucleus ambiguous
that is one of the
nuclei that contributes
to the vagus nerve
and in particular this
is the motor component
all right so that
covers the hoarseness
here because the larynx
is hemi paralyzed all
right so only half
of the vocal cords are
working the other half
are sort of held
consistently half open.
So you get this hoarse
quality to the voice.
And that just leaves
our nucleus and
tract solitarius,
or the solitary
tract. All right,
and that contributes
to cranial nerves
7, 9, and 10.
And it is special
sensory, so it's that
chemosensory component.
So it's going
to deal with taste
but also monitoring
the CO2 content in
the bloodstream.
And there's really
nothing about that in
the question, but there's
also nothing about
that in any of these
answer choices, okay?
And given everything
else this person is
dealing with, some
changes in their taste
are probably not
their primary concern.
Now, we do still
have this region
of descending
sympathetics,
and this is not
a particular
nucleus or anything,
but it is in
this region of
the brainstem.
So if we think about
sympathetics here
and sympathetics not
being enabled, now we
can kind of go through
these answer options.
So deviation of
tongue to the right?
No. That's going
to have to do with
that hypoglossal
nucleus. So that's
going to be
involved in medial
medullary syndrome,
but not lateral.
Diminished
vibratory sensation
from the right
extremities. Again,
that's something
we would expect
in medial medullary
syndrome, because
that's going to
have to do with that
DCML pathway and the
medial lemniscus.
Hyperreflexia in the
left extremities.
hyperreflexia is going
to be an upper motor
neuron issue so that's
something we would
expect to see more in
the cerebrum or other
portions higher in
the brain an inability
to recognize the left
side of his body this
again is something
that's going to be
dealt with in the
cerebrum and this goes
beyond numbness right the
inability to recognize
like you look at
your left arm and you
just don't think it's
part of your body.
And that, again, is
going to be probably
a middle cerebral
artery issue. It's
going to have to do
with dealing with
components of the
frontal and parietal, and
I think temporal lobe
is involved there
too. Anyway, that's
not what we're
dealing with here.
And then finally, we
have that right-sided
ptosis and meiosis.
That's our choice,
all right? So that's
dealing with the
sympathetics and the fact
that the sympathetics
are not working.
So that's just
coming back to the
original text of
this. So we're dealing
with the Horner
syndrome, which is
the lack of
sympathetics as a
component of lateral
medullary syndrome.
And there's our right
-sided ptosis and meiosis.
So one thing I want
to point out because,
you know, we dealt with
ptosis in case one and
case two here. and in
case one it was coming
from the oculomotor
nerve and now we're
having it as a sympatum
of the sympathetics
and I think this is
a point that confuses
students so remember that
there are two different
muscles that control
the upper eyelid all
right you have a
somatic muscle that's
controlled by the
oculomotor nerve that's the
levator palpebrae
superioris but there is also
what we call the superior
tarsal muscle and
that's a really small
smooth muscle in the
eyelid and that is
controlled by sympathetics
so keep in mind that
there are two different
sources for ptosis and
that drooping eyelid
it could be damaged
to oculomotor nerve
it could also be a
problem with sympathetics
both of those will
lead to that drooping
eyelid and I already
said this but the blood
vessel that's causing,
that would be involved
in this lateral medullary
syndrome is pica,
all right, posterior
inferior
cerebellar artery.
It can be the vertebral
artery itself,
but most commonly
when we're talking
about this
lateral medullary
syndrome, we're
probably thinking pica.
And in this case,
right, this was
probably brought on
by, and this is a
reasonably common
occurrence, right, with
chiropractic treatment
for neck pain.
They're a little
too aggressive with
that. With twisting
the neck, you get
a small tear in that
vertebral artery.
It produces a clot
that then gets thrown
off into the vertebral
artery itself
or one of its branches
like pica. And
that can lead to
this kind of ******.
So that's all we have
for today. I hope this
has been informative
and I hope that we
will see you all in
the live session where
we'll go through more
questions like this.
For review, here's a
few different sources.
And again, more
practice items coming
in the review
session as always
we appreciate your
feedback so let
us know what you
think bye everyone